Guten Tag, mein Name ist Bulur. Ich bin die Di's Talbende Erstin auf der Station und würde gerne das erste Gespräch mit Ihnen führen. Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, natürlich Frau Doktor.
Ok, zuerst werde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen. Dann können wir Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen. Und wie heißen Sie?
Ja, ich bin Helga Schmidt.
Helga Schmidt.
Ja.
Frau Schmidt, könnten Sie Ihren Vornamen und Nachricht bestabieren?
Ja, Helga Schmidt mit H-E-L-G-A.
F-T-H-M-I-D-T.
I-D-T. Ok. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ja, ich bin ungefähr 45.
Ok. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
5. Mai 1980.
Ok.
Ich bin geboren.
Wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
Ja, ungefähr 1 Meter 67.
Ok. Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja Frau Doktor, zwei und 70 Kilogramm.
Ok. Wie heißt Ihre Hausarztin?
Ja, meine Hausarztin heißt Föller.
Ja, Föller. Herr Föller.
Mit double L, mit double L, Föller.
Ja, mit Doppel L.
Ok. Und sind Sie gesetzlich oder privat gesetzlich?
Ja, ich habe AOK Versicherung.
Ok. Danke schön für diese Informationen Frau Schmidt.
Und was für Sie heute so?
Ja Frau Doktor, habe ich jetzt starke Bauchschmerzen.
Es ist schlimm geworden seit zwei Tagen, aber seit zwei Wochen habe ich Bauchschmerzen.
Aber heute kann ich nicht ertragen.
Ok, Sie haben Bauchschmerzen. Wo genau sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Vielleicht im Mittel- oder Oberbauch.
Oberbauch, linke oder rechte Seite?
Mit Mittel- und Oberbauch. Nicht rechts, nicht links.
Ok. Mit Oberbauch. Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie seit zwei Wochen diese Schmerzen gehabt haben.
Und gibt es eine bestimmte Auslösung für Ihre Schmerzen?
Meine Schmerzen haben allmählich angefangen. Langsam.
Aber ich habe bemerkt, dass meine Schmerzen nach Alkohol trinken oder Gewürz essen begonnen sind.
Und seit dem Verlauf der Zeit verschlimmert.
Ok. Haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden vor zwei Wochen gehabt?
Nein, das ist das erste Mal Frau Doktor.
Ok. Haben Sie bemerkt, was diese Schmerzen verstärkt oder lindert bis auf Essen oder Alkohol?
Zum Beispiel Bewegung oder Lageabhängung?
Nein, Lage oder Bewegung abhängig nicht. Aber mit Essen meine Schmerzen verschlimmert.
Deswegen esse ich nicht seit zwei Tagen. Ich kann nicht essen.
Seit zwei Tagen habe ich sehr schlimme Schmerzen.
Ok. Haben Sie auch Übelkeit oder Erbrechen?
Ja, ich habe Übelkeit. Seit zwei oder drei Tagen habe ich Übelkeit. Aber ich habe mich nicht übergeben.
Ok. Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlösen oder Stuhlgang?
Ja, beim Wasserlösen ist ganz normal. Aber ich habe Verstopfung Frau Doktor. Aber das ist lange geübt.
Lange geübt? Ok. Wann war Ihre Letztes Stuhl?
Das war vor zwei Tagen denke ich.
Ok. Haben Sie auch Foliegefühl oder Foliegefühl?
Ja, ich habe Foliegefühl. Ich fühle Hunger.
Foliegefühl habe ich.
Sehr selten, aber manchmal fühle ich Sauerkäse im Mund. Aber das ist sehr selten.
Ok. Haben Sie ein Druckgefühl im Bauch?
Ja, ich habe Blödsinn. Deswegen fühle ich Druckgefühl manchmal.
Aber mein Schmerz ist wie krampfartig. Manchmal kommt, manchmal geht weg. Und das ist viel leid.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10? Wobei ein sehr lafter 10 sehr starkes Schmerzen entspricht?
Ja, jetzt oder gestern? Jetzt. Jetzt ist es stark. Ich denke 7. Aber wenn mein Schmerzen angefangen hat, war es vielleicht 2 oder 3. Und jetzt 7.
Ok. Könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzen bis zum Ende des Gesprächs aushalten oder brauchen Sie einen Schmerzmittel?
Wie viele Minuten oder Stunden dauert unser Gespräch, Frau Doktor?
Unser Gespräch dauert ca. 10 Minuten.
Ja, ich kann das ertragen. Ich kann warten bis zum Ende.
Ok. Haben Sie Goldbrennen auch?
Ja, habe ich Goldbrennen auch. Sie haben recht.
Ok. Haben Sie Hüsten oder Atemnot?
Nein, habe ich keine Hüsten oder keine Atemnot. Aber mein Schmerz ist wie etwas brennendes Schmerz.
Ok. Haben Sie Schmerzen im Brust auch?
Nein, ich habe keine Schmerzen im Brustkorb.
Nicht im Brustkorb, unter dem Oberbauch.
Ok. Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzstorben oder Herzkloven?
Nein, habe ich keine.
Schmerzen Sie auch an einem anderen Körper?
Ja, ich habe ein bisschen Rücken, aber ich habe Oberbauch und Rücken.
Ok.
Ich habe einen Brustkorb, aber niemand hat meinen Oberbauch.
Ok. Ihre Schmerzen sind brennende, bohrende, krampfartige Schmerzen.
Ja, Sie haben recht, Frau Doktor.
Ok. Schlafen Sie gut?
Seit zwei Tagen kann ich nicht schlafen, Frau Doktor. Wegen Magenschmerzen oder Bauchschmerzen kann ich nicht schlafen.
Ok. Haben Sie Ihre Ernährung in Lessezeit umgestellt?
Ja, ich esse immer gleich Ernährung und trinke ab und zu natürlich Alkohol, aber ich habe nicht geändert.
Ok. Könnten Sie etwas vor der Benes gegessen haben?
Vor der Benes gegessen? Nein, ich esse immer im Kanton bei der Arbeit und zu Hause koche ich selbst und immer esse ich frisches Essen.
Ok. Haben Sie irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ja, was meinen Sie mit chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ich habe Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankung ...
Ja, ich habe Bluthochdruck seit 10 Jahren.
Ok. Und was?
Ich habe Migräne seit 5 Jahren und habe manchmal sehr stark Rückenschmerzen.
Und ich habe auch mal eine Art Schatmea gesagt, die ich diskutieren möchte.
Seit wann haben Sie Rückenschmerzen?
Seit vielleicht 7 Jahren habe ich manchmal Rückenschmerzen.
Ok. Was haben Sie regelmäßig mitgekommen?
Wenn ich Schmerzen habe, nehme ich Ibuprofen ab und zu.
Welche Dose haben Sie?
Ja, vielleicht 500 mg.
Ok.
Und ich nehme Ramiplil regelmäßig morgens 5 mg. Und wenn ich Kopfschmerzen habe, nehme ich Kryptan.
Ok. Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, einmal wurde ich operiert, weil meine Gebärmutter entfand.
Ok.
Mit 38 Jahren.
Ich hatte unregelmäßige Blutung. Deswegen besuchte ich meine Frau Arztin und sofort hat sie mich operiert.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das korrekt war oder falsch, aber meine Gebärmutter ist weg.
Ich war sehr traurig.
Ja, das war eine schwierige Situation.
Und brauchen Sie Frasch mit?
Ja, ich rauche gerne, Frau Doktor. 10 Zigaretten pro Tag.
10 Zigaretten pro Tag rauche ich. Ich habe viel Stress, Frau Doktor. Rauchen geht mir gut.
Ok. Was machen Sie wirklich? Warum haben Sie so viel Stress?
Ich arbeite als Stadtbeamter im Landratsamt. Deswegen habe ich sehr viel Stress.
Ich trinke sehr oft Kaffee beim Arbeit.
3 oder 4 Gläser Kaffee trinke ich.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ab und zu. Ja, als habe ich gesagt, ab und zu trinke ich.
2 Gläser Wein manchmal.
2 Gläser Wein, einmal oder zweimal pro Woche.
Ein oder zweimal. Ok.
Hatten Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ja, als ich im Gymnasium war, hatte ich 2 oder 3 Mal Joint geraucht.
Joint?
Ja, das war Marihuana. Wissen Sie schon?
Ich habe keine Erfahrung mit Marihuana.
Ich verstehe Sie. Ok.
Haben Sie irgendeine Allergie?
Ich habe Nusse Allergie. Wenn ich Nusse esse, habe ich Yukreis.
Ok. Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, vollständig. Kinderkrankheit oder Corona?
Alle Impfungen bekommen.
Ok.
Waren Sie in den letzten 6 Monaten im Ausland?
Nein, nein, war ich nicht.
Ok. Sind Sie verheiratet Frau Schmidt?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe 2 Kinder.
Ok. Sind Sie gesund?
Gott sei Dank, sie sind gesund. Aber manchmal streiten wir mit meinem Mann.
Deswegen habe ich auch Stress zu Hause.
Ok, ich verstehe.
Und gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen?
Mein Vater ist ganz gesund, ich kann sagen.
Gesunder Alkohol. Aber meine Mutter hat Zuckerkrankheit.
Und?
Typ 2 oder Typ 1?
Seit 20 Jahren hat sie aber ich weiß nicht ob.
Typ 1 oder Typ 2? Ich weiß nicht.
Und hat sie einen Hirninfarkt erlitten. Vor 5 Jahren.
Vor 5 Jahren?
Ja.
Ok. Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe einen Bruder.
Ist er gesund? Oder hat er eine Erkrankung?
Er ist gesund, aber hat vielleicht Bluthochdruck.
Ok. Frau Schmidt, ich habe meine aller wichtigen Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen? Oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, Frau Doktor. Habe ich sehr stark Bauchschmerzen.
Kann das Magenkrebs sein? Oder?
Ok. Frau Schmidt, ich verstehe Sie wissen was Sie haben.
Sie wissen was Sie haben. Aber Ihre Beschwerden können viele Ursachen haben.
Und bitte Sie sollten nicht nur an die schlimmsten Fälle denken.
Im Moment gibt es keinen Grund für Angst.
Auch unser Team ist sehr qualifiziert und hat viel Erfahrung.
Wir machen alle nötigen Untersuchungen. Und dann schauen wir weiter.
Welche Untersuchungen?
Ich möchte die Körperlichung untersuchen.
Dann Blutabnehmen.
Dann würde ich eine Abdomenultraschall-Ferran lassen.
Wenn ich alle Ergebnisse erhalte, informieren Sie mich.
Was ist Abdomenultraschall?
Abdomenultraschall ist eine Schmerzfüri-Untersuchung.
Das ist Schmerzfilial und Röntgenstrahlung.
Mit der Hilfe eines Abdomenultraschalls können wir die inneren Organe und Gefäße gut beurteilen.
Das ist sehr einfach.
Das dauert sehr lange.
Muss ich eine Röhre legen? Ich habe Platz an.
Nein.
Wir haben einen Kopf mit Scherz.
Wir beurteilen die inneren Organe auf den Bauch.
Okay.
Jetzt bitte liegen Sie sich unter der Untersuchung.
Ich werde Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Danke Frau Doktor.
Herr Oberarzt, ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie eine Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Der Patient ist Helga Schmidt.
Er ist 43 Jahre alt.
Er ist mit 760 Kilo groß und mit 72 Kilo schwer.
Frau Schmidt ist heute bei uns.
Seit zwei Tagen sind wir mit dem Schmerzen langsam aufgetreten.
Im Verlauf wurde es schlimmer.
Alkohol zu konsumieren und zu essen ist ein Schmerz.
Verstärken sich die Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzen sind krampfartig, brennende und bohrende Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzen strahlen den Rücken aus.
Die Schmerzen liegen bei 7 von 10 auf einer Schmerzkala.
Die Schmerzen sind sehr schwer.
Der Patient klagt über ein Hebeischwerden seit zwei Wochen.
Seit zwei Tagen ist sein Schmerzen schlimmer geworden.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unaufhängig bis auf Schmerzbedingte im Somnium und in der Appatens.
Der Patient klagt über auch Pirosis, Blechungen und volle Gefühle.
In allen Erkrankungen leidet sie seit zehn Jahren Arteriellehypertonie, seit fünf Jahren Migräne und seit sieben Jahren habe die Patienten Rücken Schmerzen.
Sie nehmen regelmäßig Romypryl 5 mg morgens und auch aus Erdamm nehmen die Patienten Triptan gegen Migräne und Ibuprofen gegen Rücken Schmerzen.
Bei den Patienten würde im Alter von 36 Jahren eine Hysteroktomie aufgrund Blutung durchgeführt werden.
Sie riechen seit zehn Zigaretten pro Tag und trinken gelegentlich Alkohol.
Die Patienten haben gesagt, sie benutzen Marihuana in der Nahrung.
Sie haben gesagt, sie benutzen Marihuana in der Nahrung.
Sie haben Marihuana in der Nahrung geräuchert.
Sie ist verheiratet, hat zwei gesunde Kinder und arbeitet als Stadtbeamter.
Sie hat viel Stress in der Arbeit. Sie hat Allergien gegen Nüsse, was sich ausübt.
Sie ist vollständig geübt und Reiseanamnese war unauffällig.
In der Familie Anamnese werden angegeben, ihr Vater sei gesund und ihre Mutter leidet an Diabetes-Militär-Typ 2.
Sie hat vor fünf Jahren eine Apoplexerlitze. Sie leidet an Arteriellehypertonie.
In der Familie Anamnese werden die Kinder in der Familie geübt.
Sie haben eine Apoplexerlitze. Sie haben eine Apoplexerlitze.
Ich würde eine Öservago-Gasrodiodynoskopie wie schnell es möglich ist planen.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, schlage ich die Volgendentherapie vor.
Ich empfehle die Patienten, die Ambulanten zu behandeln.
Ich schreibe und verschiebe die Patienten eine Schmerzverschiebung.
Während ÖGD haben wir eine Hekobakterplurie zu bestätigen.
Ich empfehle die Patienten, die Antibiotik zu beginnen.
Welche Antibiotik verschreiben Sie?
Für die Erleidikation der Hekobakterplurie verschreibe ich Chlorotromisin und Doxacycline mit Protonpomphahema.
Wie lange dauert diese Therapie?
Ca. 14 Tage dauert sie.
Herr Kollegen, Sie haben gesagt, als differential Diagnose denke ich, Kolangitis. Können Sie uns die Kolangitis ausschließen?
Okay.
Als Kolangitis ausschließen würde ich Abdominal Sonographie durchführen.
In der Laborkontersehung überprüfe ich einige Labowerte.
Ich erwarte diese Werte.
Ich erwarte auch eine Ablase, Lippase oder LDH.
Aber in einem Unkusteptikus erwarte ich keine.
Welche Laborparameter würden Sie bestimmen lassen?
Für den Unkusteptikus?
Ja, für den Unkusteptikus.
Bei der Laboruntersuchung würde ich ein großes Blut mit Entzündung parametern.
Ich möchte auch Nierenwerte oder Lebewerte beurteilen.
Ich würde Lebewerte und Nierenwerte beurteilen.
In diesem Fall würde ich einen Hemokultest machen.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall EKG schreiben?
Ja, natürlich.
Warum?
Der Patient kann eine Herzstörung haben.
Deshalb möchte ich einen EKG schreiben und auch die Herzentzüge überprüfen.
Die Herzinfarkt ausüben.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie eine Össefagogasrodionoscopy haben.
Können Sie uns die Össefagogasrodionoscopy erklären?
Ja, ich möchte erklären.
Wir beurteilen die Össefagogasrodionoscopy.
Wir benutzen einen flexiblen Schlauch für diese Untersuchungen.
Der flexible Schlauch hat vorne eine Kamera.
Wir beurteilen diesen Schlauch bis 12 Uhr.
Während der Untersuchungen nehmen wir eine Gewebeprobe.
Wir machen diese Untersuchungen ohne Betäubung.
Wenn der Patient möchte, können wir ein Beruhigensmittel verabreichen.
Wir machen eine lokale Betäubung mit einem Spray in der Maut.
Die Untersuchungen dauern ca. 30 Minuten.
Das ist eine Schmerzfüßung.
Braucht man eine Vorbereitung?
Ja, natürlich. Der Patient muss 12 Stunden vor dem Essen und Trinken.
Ja, 6 Stunden. Aber ich möchte 12 Stunden.
Darf der Patient nach der Untersuchung alle Sachen machen?
Ja, einige Stunden.
Ich empfehle den Patienten nur etwas trinken.
Aber etwa 4 Stunden kann der Patient etwas essen.
Nach der Untersuchung darf der Patient keine wichtigen Sachen machen.
Zum Beispiel darf der Patient keine selbst autofahren oder wichtige Verträge unterschreiben.
Ja, ich habe das verstanden.
Ich empfehle den Patienten nicht autofahren oder einige Stunden allein bleiben.
Unser Betäubungsmittel wird ganz am Tag.
Aber ich möchte nicht eine Betäubung machen.
Mindestens braucht man örtische Betäubung und auch leichte Schlafmittel.
Was beachten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ich beurteile den Allgemeinen und Ernährungszustand der Patienten.
Ich werde den Allgemeinen und Ernährungszustand der Patienten beurteilen.
Ich werde die Abdomen untersuchen.
Zuerst werde ich alle Bauch- und Abdomen inspektieren.
Ich werde die Abdomen für eine Vergrößerte oder eine Hautveränderung untersuchen.
Dann werde ich alle Abdomen untersuchen.
Ich werde schmerzhaft und drück- schmerzhaft und loslassen Schmerz und abgeschwannhaft.
Dann werde ich die Abdomen hören und die Darmgeräusche beurteilen.
Der Patient kann eine Herzstörung haben.
Deshalb höre ich das Herz ab.
Vielen Dank, Herr Kollegen. Unsere Zeit ist um.